From NPR, this is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We all love to buy stuff. The best part is, we don't even have to pay for anything immediately. Get lucky and own a new motorcycle for no money down, no interest for 90 days, no payments for 120 days. Celebrate for the July with cold packs, paying no interest for 16 months. That's five full years. So I use my free money limited card. Even when I'm spending on money, 1.5% cash back with everything I buy.
来自NPR，这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们都喜欢买东西。最棒的是，我们甚至不需要立即支付任何费用。运气好的话，零首付就能拥有一辆新摩托车，90天免息，120天免付款。用冷饮庆祝七月，享受16个月的免息期。那就是整整五年。所以我使用我的免费额度卡。即使我在花钱，我买的所有东西也能享受1.5%的现金返还。
It's like free money. Policy makers even tell us that a healthy economy is built on spending. So getting that second credit card is not just good for us, but good for everyone. But there's a catch. In a downturn, when people lose their jobs, what are the consequences of all the debt we've taken on?
这就像是免费的钱。政策制定者甚至告诉我们，健康的经济是建立在消费的基础上的。所以获得第二张信用卡不仅对我们有好处，对每个人都有好处。但这里有个问题。在经济低迷时期，当人们失去工作时，我们背负的所有债务会带来什么后果？
Is borrowing our way out of every crisis really sustainable? Ultimately, it has to be that we tackle the more fundamental issue, which is why is there so much death, why are people borrowing well beyond their means? This week on Hidden Brain, the Hidden Manipulator behind our debt binge and how to make a system that works better for everyone. The United States is officially in recession. Tens of millions are out of work, and many businesses are closed. With the end of the COVID-19 pandemic nowhere in sight, unemployment rates are forecast to stay high for a very long time. As we try to understand what lies ahead, we decided to first look back.
靠借债来摆脱每一次危机真的可持续吗？归根结底，我们必须解决更根本的问题，那就是为什么会有这么多的债务，为什么人们的借贷远远超出了他们的承受能力？本周的“隐藏的大脑”，我们将探讨我们的债务狂欢背后的隐秘操纵者，以及如何建立一个对每个人都更好的系统。美国已正式陷入衰退。数千万人生计无着，许多企业倒闭。由于COVID-19大流行的结束遥遥无期，预计失业率将在很长一段时间内保持高位。在我们试图了解前方道路的同时，我们决定首先回顾过去。
At the University of Chicago, economist Amir Sufi has a counterintuitive thesis about the real cause of the Great Recession of 2007 and 2008. Later in the conversation, we'll talk about how is ideas relate to the recession brought on by the COVID-19 pandemic. I started by asking him to paint a picture of what happened in the run-up to the Great Recession in cities like his own birthplace of Detroit. So, beginning first in 1998,
在芝加哥大学，经济学家阿米尔·苏菲对2007年和2008年大衰退的真正原因有一个反直觉的论点。在接下来的对话中，我们将讨论他的观点与COVID-19大流行引发的衰退有何联系。我首先请他描绘一下大衰退前夕，像他的出生地底特律这样的城市所发生的情况。所以，从1998年开始，
but then really accelerating in 2003, 2004 and 2005, there just was this explosive increase in the availability of mortgage credit. Too many high interest monthly payments. Why not pay them off with a second mortgage? There was a real push to get people to borrow against their houses, people who already own their houses, and also for people who were looking for properties to actually be able to get them mortgage. Call McKeown mortgage, get approved before you shop for home.
但在2003年、2004年和2005年真正加速，抵押贷款的供应量出现了爆炸式增长。太多高利率的每月还款了。为什么不用第二笔抵押贷款把它们还清呢？当时有一股真正的推动力，让人们用他们的房子进行抵押贷款，那些已经拥有房子的人，以及那些寻找房产的人能够真正获得抵押贷款。致电麦克凯恩抵押贷款公司，在您购买房屋之前获得批准。
This was reflected in, for example, the home ownership rate went up dramatically from about 1998 to 2006. And it was the first time that a lot of people, especially people with low credit scores, with low incomes, were able to actually buy properties. That's something that happened. We give the example, for example, in Detroit. It also happened on the south and west sides of Chicago. And so we really think it was kind of a push factor that all of a sudden, it was almost as if people were kind of being asked to borrow more, more than people really seeking to borrow more.
这体现在，例如，大约从1998年到2006年，房屋自有率急剧上升。这是许多人，特别是信用评分低、收入低的人，第一次真正能够购买房产。这就是发生的事情。我们举个例子，比如在底特律。这也发生在芝加哥的南部和西部。因此，我们真的认为这是一种推力，突然之间，几乎就像是人们在某种程度上被要求借更多的钱，而不是人们真正寻求借更多的钱。
Mortgage companies sent people house to house, knocking on doors, trying to get them to take out second mortgages. It was unreal. The easy access to money meant that all of a sudden people were flush with cash, with increased demand, home prices skyrocketed, even in poor parts of the country. Then the recession struck. In Merced County, California, home values plunged 50%. Nearly two in three homeowners in Merced found themselves underwater.
抵押贷款公司派人挨家挨户敲门，试图让人们申请第二笔抵押贷款。这太不真实了。容易获得资金意味着突然之间人们手头现金充裕，需求增加，房价飙升，甚至在贫困地区也是如此。然后衰退袭来。在加利福尼亚州的默塞德县，房屋价值暴跌了50%。默塞德近三分之二的房主发现自己资不抵债。
The old more than their homes were worth. It's a destruction of wealth that's close to unprecedented and that destruction of wealth is really occurring and hitting hardest people in the, say, middle and lower income ranges, even into the upper middle class. So that is, this is actually even amplified by the fact that middle-class households rely on home equity as their main source of wealth. Middle-income Americans generally don't have huge pensions, they don't usually have a lot of wealth in the stock market, a lot of wealth in bonds. And so housing really is the heart of their wealth. And as a result, as a big decline in house prices really hits that group of people the hardest when it happens.
旧债超过了他们房屋的价值。这种财富的毁灭几乎是空前绝后的，而这种财富的毁灭正在发生，并对中低收入阶层，甚至上中产阶级的人打击最大。因此，中产阶级家庭依靠房屋净值作为其主要财富来源这一事实，实际上加剧了这种情况。中产收入的美国人通常没有巨额养老金，他们通常在股市中没有大量财富，在债券中也没有大量财富。因此，住房确实是他们财富的核心。因此，房价的大幅下跌在发生时确实对这群人打击最大。
One of the consequences of a build up in debt is that when things turn sour, people in debt cut back dramatically on their spending. Eventually, there's also effects people who are not part of the borrowing boom. They get affected because demand is collapsing for products and services. They may lose their jobs. Soon, they are also forced to cut back on spending and the vicious cycle accelerates. The example we give in our book actually is the one in Tennessee. In Tennessee, we have a lot of manufacturing plants of cars, of automobiles.
债务积累的后果之一是，当情况变坏时，负债的人会大幅削减开支。最终，这也影响到那些不属于借贷热潮的人。他们受到影响是因为产品和服务的需求正在崩溃。他们可能会失业。很快，他们也被迫削减开支，恶性循环加速了。我们在书中举的例子实际上是田纳西州的例子。在田纳西州，我们有很多汽车制造厂。
And we give the example of Senator Bob Corcor, who basically said, we in Tennessee shouldn't care about the irresponsible borrowing that people on the East Coast and the West Coast were doing. And we then go through the statistics and show that in fact a lot of people manufacturing cars in Tennessee lost their jobs in 2007 and 2008. And it almost has to be because the cut in demand that was happening on these coast. So in that sense, Senator Bob Corker is not seeing the full picture that what is happening on the coast is directly affecting his constituents. So a lot of people attribute the great recession to a banking crisis, to the collapse of, you know, Lehman Brothers and other financial institutions. But when you look closely at the data, you
我们举了参议员鲍勃·科克的例子，他基本上说，我们田纳西州不应该关心东海岸和西海岸的人们不负责任的借贷行为。然后我们梳理了统计数据，显示事实上田纳西州许多制造汽车的人在2007年和2008年失去了工作。这几乎必然是因为这些海岸正在发生的需求下降。从这个意义上说，参议员鲍勃·科克没有看到全貌，海岸上发生的事情正在直接影响他的选民。因此，很多人将大衰退归咎于银行业危机，归咎于雷曼兄弟和其他金融机构的崩溃。但当你仔细查看数据时，你会
find that they were warning signals well before the troubles that arose in the banking sector. What were those signals? For example, household spending started to collapse in 2007, especially household spending on what we call durable goods, these are cars or furniture or recreational vehicles. In fact, even in the summer of 2008, which is of course prior to the banking crisis, you see pretty dramatic declines in household spending,
发现早在银行业出现问题之前，就有警告信号了。这些信号是什么？例如，家庭消费在2007年开始崩溃，特别是家庭对我们称之为耐用品的消费，这些是汽车、家具或休闲车。事实上，甚至在2008年夏天，也就是银行业危机之前，你就能看到家庭消费出现相当急剧的下降，
you see pretty dramatic declines in what we call residential investment, which is just a fancy way of saying construction, the building of homes. These were already seriously dragging down the overall economy. And in fact, the easiest way to see this is that the official dating agency, the National Bureau of Economic Research, they date the start of the recession
你可以看到我们所谓的住宅投资出现相当急剧的下降，这只是一种华丽的说法，指建筑业，即房屋的建造。这些已经严重拖累了整个经济。事实上，看到这一点的最简单方法是，官方的数据发布机构，即国家经济研究局，将衰退的开始时间定在
in the fourth quarter of 2007, which is almost a whole year before Lehman Brothers, before the banking crisis. Let's underline this. With the advantage of hindsight, we now see the Great Recession started a year before the collapse of Lehman Brothers. The same pattern is also evident worldwide. Countries like Ireland and Denmark that saw painful economic contractions had something in common with places like Merced and Detroit. They were places that saw
2007年第四季度，这几乎比雷曼兄弟倒闭、比银行危机早了整整一年。让我们强调这一点。事后看来，我们现在看到大衰退始于雷曼兄弟倒闭前一年。同样的模式在世界各地也很明显。爱尔兰和丹麦等经历痛苦经济收缩的国家，与默塞德和底特律等地方有一个共同点。它们都是经历了
a steep build-up in borrowing. Armour says you can see the same pattern historically. Interestingly, there's been a huge amount of research that the recession has spawned and looking not just at other countries during the Great Recession, but even historical episodes like the Great Depression like different crises that have occurred in other countries. And a pretty systematic pattern is there in the data, which is the crisis, the banking crisis, the financial crisis should be thought of as a symptom, not a cause, that the cause usually is some decline in house prices or some other decline
借贷急剧积累的地方。阿米尔说，从历史上看，你可以看到同样的模式。有趣的是，衰退催生了大量研究，不仅着眼于大衰退期间的其他国家，甚至还着眼于历史上的事件，如大萧条，以及其他国家发生的不同危机。数据中存在一个相当系统的模式，即危机、银行危机、金融危机应该被视为一种症状，而不是原因，其原因通常是房价的某种下跌或其他下跌，
and other asset prices like stock prices. And as a result of that decline, then a banking panic happens or a banking crisis. I want to be clear, obviously the banking crisis and Lehman Brothers makes the recession far worse than it would have been in the absence of the crisis. But it's better to think of it as more of a symptom rather than a cause, at least of the initial economic downturn that usually happens in these episodes. So it's worth pointing out, of course, that the take that you have is not a take that's universally shared. There are people who believe that the real drivers of recessions do lie in the backing sector
以及其他资产价格如股票价格的下跌。由于这种下跌，才会发生银行挤兑或银行危机。需要明确的是，显然银行危机和雷曼兄弟事件使得衰退比没有危机时要糟糕得多。但最好将其视为一种症状，而不是原因，至少是这些事件中通常发生的初始经济低迷的原因。因此，值得指出的是，你的观点当然并非普遍赞同。有些人认为，衰退真正的驱动因素确实在于银行业，
or in irrational currents of fear that sweep through an economy from time to time. You write economic disasters are almost always preceded by a large increase in household debt. In fact, the correlation is so robust that it is as close to an empirical law as it gets in macroeconomics. How do you think that theory is seen by your fellow economists? Is this widely shared? Is this a contested idea? Is it a stretch? I think when we first wrote our research, it was considered
或者在于不时席卷经济的非理性恐惧潮流。你写道，经济灾难几乎总是伴随着家庭债务的大幅增加。事实上，这种相关性如此稳健，以至于它在宏观经济学中几乎算得上是一个经验规律。你认为你的同行经济学家是如何看待这一理论的？这个观点是广泛共识吗？这是一个有争议的想法吗？这有些牵强吗？我想当我们刚写完我们的研究时，它被认为
maybe a fringe idea. I think since then, the research has confirmed this observation. There's a lot of research that's been conducted over the last five or ten years that have shown not just the great recession but more systematically in a number of different countries that increases in credit and in particular increases in household debt are systematically related to economic downturns. I'm thinking in particular by research, by Atrio, Yorta, Schulrich, and Taylor are their last names, and they collect data going all the way back to the 19th century across 17 advanced countries. And they basically show that this pattern is very systematic.
可能是一个边缘观点。我认为从那时起，研究已经证实了这一观察。在过去五到十年里进行的许多研究表明，不仅在大衰退中，而且在许多不同的国家中，信贷的增加，特别是家庭债务的增加，与经济低迷有着系统的联系。我特别想到的是阿特里奥、约尔塔、舒尔里奇和泰勒的研究（这是他们的姓氏），他们收集了可以追溯到19世纪、横跨17个发达国家的数据。他们基本上表明这种模式非常系统化。
It's there in the data. People and economics usually come into discussions with their own views about how the way the world works. We think the data speak for themselves. I think at this point there's enough data out there that people are almost forced to take very seriously the idea that it's something about credit, debt, in particular household debt that seems to be related to business cycles and macroeconomic fluctuations. There's a great mystery in this economic boom and bust. Why will
它就在数据里。人们和经济学家在进行讨论时，通常带着他们自己关于世界运作方式的观点。我们认为数据会说话。我认为在这一点上，已经有足够的数据让人们几乎不得不非常认真地对待这样一种观点，即信贷、债务，特别是家庭债务，似乎与商业周期和宏观经济波动有关。在这个经济繁荣与萧条的过程中，存在一个巨大的谜团。为什么
lenders so anxious to give money to people with weak credit? To understand that, let's leave the world of finance for a moment and head to Hollywood. In 2009, just as the Great Recession was starting to ease, a movie came out. It was called The Joneses. It tells a story of a well-off family of four who've just arrived at their new home, a MacManchion, in an unnamed American suburb. The thing is, this family, the Joneses, they're fake. They've been planted in the neighborhood by a huge marketing company. Their job is to make the luxury goods surrounding them seem like must have products. As a senior manager reminds the husband, Steve Jones, his role is to be an influencer.
贷款人如此渴望把钱借给信用不佳的人？为了理解这一点，让我们暂时离开金融世界，前往好莱坞。2009年，正当大衰退开始缓和之际，一部电影上映了。它叫《琼斯一家》。它讲述了一个富裕的四口之家刚刚搬进美国某无名郊区的新家——一座豪华大宅的故事。问题是，这个家庭，琼斯一家，是假的。他们是由一家大型营销公司安插在这个社区的。他们的工作是让周围的奢侈品看起来像是必买产品。正如一位高级经理提醒丈夫史蒂夫·琼斯的那样，他的角色是一个影响者。
To succeed here, you can't just sell things. You're here to sell a lifestyle, an attitude. If people want you, they'll want what you've got. The movie, of course, is fiction, but Amir Sufi argues that it reflects a deep truth about American life. Corporations are constantly trying to find creative ways to get us to buy things. Somewhere along the way, they realized that one of the most profitable things to sell was not golf clubs or diamonds or convertibles, but money itself. It's just amazing how many retailers you walk into.
要想在这里成功，你不能只卖东西。你在这里是为了销售一种生活方式，一种态度。如果人们想要你，他们就会想要你拥有的东西。这部电影当然是虚构的，但阿米尔·苏菲认为它反映了美国生活的一个深刻真理。企业一直在试图寻找创造性的方法来让我们买东西。在某个过程中，他们意识到最有利可图的销售对象不是高尔夫球杆、钻石或敞篷车，而是金钱本身。走进许多零售店，真是让人惊叹。
This is true of, say, blooming dails. It's also true of, say, best buy or home depot. And you go to buy whatever product that you're going to buy and all of a sudden the sales associate, who's not, of course, any financial expert, tries to offer you a credit card or tries to offer you a charge card that you should buy this on credit. I've always found that as an economist and as a financial economist in particular very strange. Why would you find it strange? I mean on the surface it actually seems like a very helpful thing to do. You're trying to buy, let's say, a new TV and the sales associate says, you know, guess what? You don't actually have to pay for all of the
这适用于布鲁明戴尔百货公司。这也适用于百货公司，比如百货店百货公司百货店或家得宝。当你去买你要买的任何产品时，突然之间，这位当然不是任何金融专家的销售助理试图向你推荐一张信用卡，或者试图向你推荐一张赊账卡，你应该用信贷购买这个。作为一名经济学家，特别是作为一名金融经济学家，我一直觉得这非常奇怪。为什么你会觉得奇怪？我的意思是，从表面上看，这实际上似乎是一件非常有帮助的事情。比方说，你正试图买一台新电视，销售助理说，你知道吗，你其实不需要预付电视的全部费用。
TV up front. There's a way to break it up. You can get a credit card. You can put this on the credit card. You can break up the payments so that you're only paying a small amount. Maybe you can even afford a bigger TV as a result. I mean, it's provided to the customer as a service. Why is it strange? I think part of the interesting issue here is the psychology behind it, which is I'm here. I've already announced I want to buy this good. I didn't come into this store thinking that I wanted to borrow to buy it. And now there's an effort actually to get me to borrow to buy it when I otherwise may have not have even been thinking about borrowing. And so there's something going on here that's trying to
有一种分期的方法。你可以办一张信用卡。你可以把这个记在信用卡上。你可以把付款分成几部分，这样你只需要支付一小笔钱。也许因此你甚至能买得起一台更大的电视。我的意思是，这是作为一项服务提供给客户的。为什么这很奇怪？我认为这里有趣的问题之一是其背后的心理，也就是我来了。我已经宣布我想买这个商品。我走进这家店并不是为了借钱来买它。现在有人在努力让我借钱买它，而我本来可能根本没有考虑过借钱。所以这里发生了一些事情，它试图改变我对这个产品付款方式的看法。
change the way I think about the payment for this product. And it seems quite purposeful in some sense for the company to be doing this. And so maybe this is because I have a natural cynicism that an economist has, but I immediately want to think about, you know, what's in it for you? Why are you offering me this charge card when I had a basically announced I was willing to buy this without getting a charge card? What's interesting here on this is that debt has historically had a lot of stigma attached to it. Can you talk a little bit about this idea and how marketers and companies and lenders have struggled to overcome this stigma?
从某种意义上说，公司这样做似乎非常有意图。所以也许这是因为我有一种经济学家天生的愤世嫉俗，但我立刻就想考虑，你知道，这对你有什么好处？为什么你在我基本上已经宣布愿意不用赊账卡购买的情况下，还要向我提供这张赊账卡？这里有趣的是，债务在历史上带有很大的污名。你能谈谈这个想法，以及营销人员、公司和贷款人是如何努力克服这种污名的吗？
One of the things about debt that fascinates me is that a lot of cultural traditions, a lot of religious traditions, do put kind of a negative view on it that you know most spiritual traditions have this notion that you shouldn't borrow too much. Oftentimes they also have some tradition that you shouldn't be lending in at exorbitant interest rates or unfair interest rates. And so I think it becomes kind of part of our DNA that maybe we should be a little skeptical of borrowing too much. Of course if you're a company that's trying to make money off financial products, overcoming what might be kind of an ingrained aversion to debt is a big challenge. And one of the things we've noticed when we look at historical episodes,
关于债务，让我着迷的一件事是，许多文化传统、许多宗教传统确实对它抱有一种负面看法，你知道，大多数精神传统都有这样一种观念，即你不应该借太多钱。通常他们也有一些传统，即你不应该以高得离谱的利率或不公平的利率进行贷款。因此，我认为这成为我们DNA的一部分，也许我们应该对借太多钱持一点怀疑态度。当然，如果你是一家试图从金融产品中赚钱的公司，克服可能已经根深蒂固的对债务的厌恶是一个巨大的挑战。当我们回顾历史事件时，我们注意到的一件事是，
and I think the two eras that really show this quite clearly, are the 1920s and the 1980s. In both the 1920s and the 1980s, it's very clear of a systematic effort through marketing to get people to be more comfortable borrowing in order to purchase things. In the 1920s, for example, there's a woman named Martha Olney at Berkeley, and she does excellent research showing that it was necessary to do a lot of advertising, to get people to buy automobiles, sewing machines, other what we call consumer durables on credit. She basically says that prior to the 1920s, people never went into a store with the expectation that they would be using debt to purchase a product.
我认为真正清楚地展示这一点的两个时代是20世纪20年代和20世纪80年代。在20世纪20年代和20世纪80年代，通过营销进行系统性努力，让人们更习惯于为了买东西而借债，这是非常明显的。例如，在20世纪20年代，伯克利有一位名叫玛莎·奥尔尼的女性，她做了出色的研究，表明有必要进行大量的广告宣传，才能让人们信贷购买汽车、缝纫机以及我们称之为耐用消费品的其他东西。她基本上说，在20世纪20年代之前，人们走进商店时从不期望自己会使用债务来购买产品。
And the 1920s were an era in which that all changed. She talks about kind of a cultural paradigm shift that basically got people more comfortable with the notion of buying things on debt. And what happened in the 1980s? In the 1980s, interestingly, it happened in two different markets, credit card markets and the home equity market. I think most people understand credit cards, so let me focus a little bit more on home equity. A home equity line of credit or a cash out refinancing is the idea that you already own your home, you've got some equity in it, and you go to
20世纪20年代是一个一切都改变的时代。她谈到了某种文化范式的转变，这种转变基本上让人们对通过负债买东西的概念感到更加舒适。20世纪80年代发生了什么？有趣的是，在20世纪80年代，它发生在两个不同的市场，即信用卡市场和房屋净值市场。我想大多数人都了解信用卡，所以让我多关注一下房屋净值。房屋净值信贷额度或现金套现再融资是指你已经拥有你的房子，你在其中拥有一些权益，然后你去
the bank, and you basically the bank says, okay, we'll make you an additional loan in order so that you can have some cash to redo your kitchen or redo your bathroom or whatever you want to do with that money. Prior to the 1980s, the term home equity didn't even exist. It's fascinating. A home equity loan prior to the 1980s was called a second mortgage. Now, a second mortgage doesn't sound very nice. If you already have an aversion to debt,
银行，基本上银行会说，好的，我们会为你提供一笔额外的贷款，以便你能有一些现金来重新装修你的厨房或重新装修你的浴室，或者你想用这笔钱做什么。在20世纪80年代之前，“房屋净值”这个词甚至都不存在。这太迷人了。20世纪80年代之前的房屋净值贷款被称为第二笔抵押贷款。现在，第二笔抵押贷款听起来不太好听。如果你已经对债务有厌恶感，
a second mortgage is kind of like, okay, now I already had one hand cuff on and now you're gonna put ankle cuffs on me. So there was a systematic effort and this is all quite well documented and in fact we looked at our own data to see if this was true to actually invent this term, Home Equity. And the idea was, well, it's your equity in your home.
第二笔抵押贷款有点像，好吧，我以前戴着一只手铐，现在你要给我戴上脚镣。因此，有一个系统性的努力，这一切都有很好的记录，事实上我们查阅了自己的数据来验证这是否属实，那就是真正发明了“房屋净值”这个词。这个想法是，嗯，这是你在房屋中的权益。
You have every right to borrow against it. It's not a bad thing to borrow against that equity. Armour says, if you look at newspaper ads from several decades ago, you'll almost never see the term, Home Equity. That is, until about 1982 or 83. And then it skyrockets through the 80s. So in fact the data do support this idea that home equity this term was invented in order to get people to be more comfortable borrowing against their home. So who is the puppet master pulling the strings?
你完全有权以它为抵押借款。以该权益为抵押借款并不是一件坏事。阿米尔说，如果你看几十年前的报纸广告，你几乎永远看不到“房屋净值”这个词。直到1982年或83年左右。然后在80年代急剧上升。因此，事实上，数据确实支持了这样一种观点，即发明“房屋净值”这个词是为了让人门更习惯于以房屋为抵押借款。那么，谁是操纵木偶的幕后黑手？
Convincing us to take out more credit cards and to borrow money to buy more stuff. I think to understand the answer to that question, it's important to think about who ultimately is behind the money that is being offered to you. And it takes kind of a bigger picture perspective to try to answer that question. Who ultimately is so anxious to lend to you? That's when we come back. Economist Amir Sufi argues that we have failed to appreciate the role of household debt in economic crisis. We tend to think that something as big as a recession can only be caused by a tectonic upheaval, like a major financial company going under.
说服我们办更多的信用卡并借钱买更多东西。我认为要理解这个问题的答案，重要的是考虑究竟是谁在为你提供资金支持。这就需要从宏观的角度来尝试回答这个问题。究竟是谁如此急于把钱借给你？这就是我们要回到的地方。经济学家阿米尔·苏菲认为，我们未能认识到家庭债务在经济危机中的作用。我们倾向于认为，像经济衰退这样的大事只能由地壳运动般的剧变引起，比如一家大金融公司倒闭。
We fail to see how the debt we build up as individuals, buying things we don't need, with money we don't have, can have profound effects on our lives and the larger economy. Army wrote a book about this called How's of Death, along with Princeton University Economist Atef Mian. It describes an enormous engine that is constantly trying to get us to borrow more money. This presents a mystery. Who is so anxious to lend to us? Where is all this money coming from?
我们没有看到，我们作为个人积累的债务——用我们没有的钱买我们不需要的东西——会如何对我们的生活和更大的经济产生深远的影响。阿米尔就此写了一本名为《债务之家》的书，与普林斯顿大学经济学家阿特夫·米安合作。它描述了一个庞大的引擎，不断试图让我们借更多的钱。这就产生了一个谜。谁这么急着借钱给我们？所有这些钱都是从哪里来的？
To answer that question, I always say it's important to understand that banks aren't people. Or, you know, the credit card company is not a person. Banks are owned by people. I think that's important to understand. And it's important to understand who really owns the financial intermediaries that ultimately provide us with credit. And that's where we almost have to have a frank discussion about the wealth distribution and the income distribution. That is, it's the wealthy, or people very high up in the wealth distribution, that ultimately own
为了回答这个问题，我总是说，理解银行不是人，这一点很重要。或者，你知道，信用卡公司不是一个人。银行是由人拥有的。我认为理解这一点很重要。了解究竟是谁真正拥有最终为我们提供信贷的金融中介机构也很重要。这就是我们几乎必须坦诚讨论财富分配和收入分配的地方。也就是说，富人，或者财富分配中处于极高位置的人，最终拥有
the financial intermediaries that are trying to get us to borrow. And so we call this kind of a credit push story that if the people at the very top of the income distribution are earning more and more of the economy's income, that puts more and more pressure, more and more money is kind of coming into this financial sector and therefore leading to an effort to go out and make loans. So the rise in debt, the rise in credit, is very closely linked to the rise in income and equality and wealth inequality. So in other words, if I am Jeff Bezos and my net worth has gone up from a hundred billion dollars to a hundred and fifty billion dollars, I'm looking for some place
试图诱使我们借钱的金融中介机构。所以我们称这为一种信贷推动的故事，如果收入分配最顶端的人赚取了经济中越来越多的收入，这就会带来越来越多的压力，越来越多的资金流入这个金融部门，从而导致努力去发放贷款。因此，债务的增长、信贷的增长，与收入不平等和财富不平等的加剧紧密相连。换句话说，如果我是杰夫·贝索斯，我的净资产从一千亿美元增加到了一千五亿美元，我正在寻找某个地方，
where the money that I have, not just the equity I have looking for some place where the money that I have, not just the equity I have in Amazon, but the money that I'm making has a place to be invested. So I'm actually, I just don't wanna sitting under a mattress, I wanted to go out and do something. And in order for the money to go out and do something, the money has to find ways to get used. And that's where it basically gets translated
把我拥有的钱——不仅仅是我在亚马逊拥有的权益，而是我赚的钱——找一个地方投资。所以实际上，我只是不想让它躺在床垫底下，我希望它出去做点什么。为了让钱出去做点什么，这笔钱必须找到被利用的方法。这就是它基本上转化为
into this push, as you say, for people to borrow that money. Right. And that whole process starts with the observation that Jeff Bezos cannot possibly spend the money he makes. It's just too much money. So we start with this observation, when I say, we, this is research with Othtif Mian and Ludwig Straub, we start with this observation, which is that people at the very top of the
你所说的推动人们借这笔钱的力量的地方。没错。整个过程始于这样一个观察：杰夫·贝索斯不可能花掉他赚的钱。钱实在太多了。所以我们从这个观察开始，当我说“我们”时，这是与奥特夫·米安和路德维希·施特劳斯的研究，我们从这个观察开始，即处于
income distribution, the wealth distribution, just simply cannot spend all the money they make. And so as they earn more and more of the income, the more and more savings are going to enter into the financial system, we call it the saving glut of the rich. And that money, as you said, is in search of a return. And so that process, the rich making more and more money, is closely connected to why, when I walk into blooming sales, the sales associate is trying to get me to sign up for a charge card. So in other words, the rise in income inequality
收入分配、财富分配最顶端的人，根本无法花掉他们赚的所有钱。因此，随着他们赚取越来越多的收入，越来越多的储蓄将进入金融体系，我们称之为富人的储蓄过剩。正如你所说，这笔钱在寻找回报。因此，这个过程——富人赚越来越多的钱——与为什么当我走进布鲁明戴尔百货时，销售助理试图让我申请一张赊账卡密切相关。换句话说，收入不平等
or wealth inequality might actually be connected to the rise in the push to get people to borrow more of that money that the wealthy are trying to find someplace to invest. That's exactly right. One of the interesting points is that it's not necessary that that happens. In a well-functioning economy, we would like to think that the money Jeff Bezos saves into the financial system goes out and it finds productive investment opportunities. Whatever, it helps to build a bridge or it helps to build a business.
或财富不平等的加剧，实际上可能与推动人们借更多富人正试图寻找地方投资的资金的力度加大有关。完全正确。有趣的一点是，这并非必然发生。在一个运转良好的经济体中，我们倾向于认为杰夫·贝索斯存入金融系统的钱会流出去，并找到生产性的投资机会。无论如何，它有助于建造一座桥梁或有助于建立一项业务。
But one of the things that's very striking is that that just is not happening. That even though the rich are saving more and more of their income, the money is being used to facilitate borrowing by everyone other than the rich. And by borrowing, I mean borrowing by people in the bottom, 90% of the income distribution, borrowing by governments, for example. A lot of people don't see this connection that the government is ultimately also borrowing from Jeff Bezos in some broad sense. And so it almost has to be that there's so much more debt if the rich are saving more and more of their money. This is not just a story about what is happening within the United States. Across the world, many countries seeking to stash their money somewhere safe look to invest it in the United States.
但非常引人注目的一点是，这种情况根本没有发生。尽管富人存下了越来越多的收入，但这笔钱却被用来为除富人之外所有人的借贷提供便利。我所说的借贷，是指收入分配底层90%的人的借贷，例如政府的借贷。许多人没有看到这种联系，即政府在某种广义上最终也是在向杰夫·贝索斯借钱。因此，如果富人存下越来越多的钱，几乎必然会有这么多的债务。这不仅仅是关于美国境内发生的事情的故事。在世界各地，许多寻求将资金藏在安全地方的国家都在寻求将其投资于美国。
And that's something that has been referred to as the global saving glut. If you put these two factors together, the saving glut of the rich and the global saving glut, they're very related. It's all about a group of people in the economy. You can think rich Americans in the United States or you can think of the Chinese Central Bank who are almost desperate to lend to people in the United States that need to borrow. And so all of that process is linked. So ultimately the mortgages being taken out in Detroit are directly linked to decisions being made by the Chinese central bank who wants to kind of, in some sense, lend more to American borrowers. So there's a potentially happy story here, and I want to understand why it is that happy
这就是所谓的全球储蓄过剩。如果你把这两个因素结合起来，富人的储蓄过剩和全球储蓄过剩，它们是非常相关的。这全关乎经济中的一群人。你可以认为美国富裕的美国人，或者你可以认为中国央行，他们几乎急于向美国需要借款的人放贷。因此，所有这些过程都是相连的。因此，最终在底特律发放的抵押贷款与中国央行的决定直接相关，中国央行希望在某种意义上向美国借款人发放更多贷款。这里有一个潜在的美好故事，我想了解为什么这个美好的故事没有发生，那就是你有富人希望他们的钱做点什么，你也有可能较穷的人希望借钱来买他们原本买不到的东西。假设发生了一场萧条。据推测，富人和穷人都身家攸关。我的意思是，富人基本上把钱借给了穷人，所以他们有资金处于危险之中，如果经济低迷，这些资金基本上会面临风险。穷人身家攸关，因为如果经济低迷，他们会发现自己资不抵债。
story doesn't happen, which is that you have rich people who want their money to do something, and you have potentially poorer people who want to borrow money in order to get things that they would not have been able to get otherwise. So let's say there's a bust. Presumably, both the rich and the poor have things at stake. I mean, the rich have basically lent money to the poor, so they have money that's at stake that basically is at risk if there's a downturn. The poor have things at stake because if there's a downturn, they're going to find themselves underwater.
但你的论点是，金融部门的实际构建方式并非如此，风险实际上并未在借款人和贷款人之间平均分配。这是怎么回事呢？这是这里进行的金融契约的性质决定的。所以让我们让它尽可能简单。排除金融部门，假设一个富裕的美国人，比如杰夫·贝索斯，直接借钱给一个不富有的人。
But you have a thesis that this is actually not the way the financial sector is actually constructed, that risk is actually not being distributed equally between borrowers and lenders. How does that come to be? It's the nature of the financial contract that's being done here. So let's make it as simple as possible. Let's take out the financial sector and just say, let's suppose a rich American, let's say Jeff Bezos, directly lends to someone who's not rich.
需要理解的重要一点是，这种金融契约就是我们所说的债务契约。现在，我们也习惯于使用债务。我们可能甚至没有意识到这到底意味着什么。债务契约到底意味着什么。现在，我们也习惯于使用债务。我们可能甚至没有意识到这到底意味着什么。那么债务契约到底意味着什么呢？除了通过一个简单的数字例子之外，没有别的办法来说明这一点。因此，假设债务人借了8万美元来买一套10万美元的房子。好的。所以房子的价值是10万美元。他们借了8万美元。假设由于他们无法控制的原因，房价随后下跌了20%。所以现在他们在这所房子里。他们拥有这所房子，房子的价值从10万美元下降到8万美元。问题是，究竟是谁亏了钱？
The important thing to understand is that that financial contract is what we call a debt contract. Now, we're also used to using debt. We probably don't even appreciate what that exactly means. What does it mean that it's a debt contract. Now we're also used to using debt. We probably don't even appreciate what that exactly means. So what does it mean that it's a debt contract? And there's no way to kind of illustrate this other than through a simple numerical example. So let's suppose the debtor borrows $80,000 to buy a $100,000 house. Okay. So the house is worth $ hundred thousand dollars. They borrow eighty thousand dollars Let's say through no fault of their own house prices then fall 20 percent So now they're in the house. They own the house the house value goes from a hundred thousand dollars to eighty thousand dollars the question is who actually lost money and
从债务运作的方式来看，顺着逻辑想一想。假设我现在去试着卖我的房子。现在我是借款人。当我把房子卖给别人时，它只值8万美元。所以他们会把8万美元汇给我。我得把房贷还清。我得付多少钱？
The fact of the way debt works think through the logic Let's suppose I go and try to sell my house now. Now I'm the borrower. When I sell the house to somebody else, it's only worth $80,000. So they're gonna wire in $80,000 to me. And I'm gonna have to pay off the mortgage. How much am I gonna have to pay?
我得付8万美元。因此，这个例子说明，作为房主的我，损失了2万美元。因此，房屋价值的全部损失都强加给权益持有人，在这个例子中就是非富裕人群的房主。在这个例子中，杰夫·贝索斯
I'm gonna have to pay $80,000. So this example illustrates that I, as the homeowner, have lost $20,000. So the entire loss of the home value is imposed on the equity holder, which of this example is the homeowner who is the non-rich person. And in this example, Jeff Bezos
实际上连一分钱都没损失。这就是债务的本质，它很微妙但极其重要。债务可以免受经济下滑的影响，至少在权益持有人或房主之前受到保护。在这种情况下，承担这种风险的是非富裕人群，即不富裕的人。我们更广泛的观点是，这看起来不是一个非常明智的系统。
actually didn't even lose his scent. And that's the nature of debt that is kind of subtle but incredibly important. That debt is protected against declines in the economy, at least protected before the equity holder is or the homeowner. And in this situation, it's the non-rich, the person who's not rich who is taking that risk. And our broader point is that doesn't seem like a very sensible system.
从某种意义上说，杰夫·贝索斯应该承担风险。他是那个有很多钱并且能够承担风险的人，而不是本例中可能没有多少其他财富的房主。所以，当然，能够省下钱的人——我们一直以杰夫·贝索斯为例，但他只是更广泛观点的代名词——真正能够放贷的人是那些生活富裕的人。既然金融系统——你提出的论点是——金融系统保护的是贷款人的利益，而不是借款人的利益，那么危机意味着富人相对安然无恙，甚至可能领先，而穷人则损失惨重，这意味着收入不平等
Jeff Bezos should in some sense be taking the risk. He's the person who has a lot of money and can afford to take risk and not the homeowner in this example who probably doesn't have a lot of other wealth. So, of course, the people who can save money and we've been using Jeff Bezos as an example, but he's only a stand-in for the larger idea that the people who actually can lend money are the people who are well off. And since the financial system, the argument you're making is that the financial system protects the interests of lenders over the interests of borrowers. A crisis means that the rich come out relatively even, or potentially even ahead, while the poor lose a lot of ground, which means that income inequality
现在进一步拉大了。完全正确，完全正确。在我们看来，这就是债务的恶性影响。我想说清楚，因为我不想把富人描绘成这个故事中的恶棍。富人用他们的钱做金融部门引导他们做的事。所以当他们把钱存入银行时，你知道，他们可能不希望银行出去发放更多抵押贷款。
now widens even further. Exactly, exactly. And that is the pernicious effect of ground, which means that income inequality now widened even further. Exactly, exactly. And that is the pernicious effect of debt in our view. And I want to be clear, because I don't want to make the rich out to seem like villains in this story. The rich do with their money what the financial sector kind of guides them to do. So when they put their money in the bank, you know, they may not want the bank to be going out and making more mortgages.
他们可能希望银行出去向企业家发放生产性商业贷款。所以我认为金融部门至少要负一些责任，是金融部门引导这笔资金以债务的形式发放给企业家、房主或其他任何需要钱的人。我们在书中提出的观点之一是，如果说有什么不同的话，那就是政府实际上鼓励了这种低效的贷款产品。例如，由于债务存在利息税盾，它们使借款成本降低。（你知道，你可以从税收中扣除利息。）它们鼓励银行仅通过债务融资进行放贷。
They may want the bank to go out and make productive business loans to entrepreneurs. So I think there is at least some blame here in the financial sector that it's the financial sector that is guiding this money to be, you know, given out to entrepreneurs, to homeowners, to whoever else needs the money in the form of debt. And one of the points we make in the book is to say that if anything, the government actually encourages exactly this kind of inefficient lending product. They, for example, make it cheaper to borrow because there's an interest tax shield on debt. You know, you get to subtract your interest off your taxes. They encourage banks to only lend via debt financing.
这是一个更广泛的问题，我想明确指出，并不是说富人是这个故事中的恶棍，只是金融部门将他们的资金引导到了更多固定收益、类似债务的产品中。我想知道你对家庭 debt 的看法，不仅如此，还有公司承担的 debt 和政府承担的 debt。它们的运作方式是一样的，还是它们之间、家庭 debt 与公司 debt 和政府 debt 之间有着根本的不同？
So it's a broader problem, and I just want to be clear, it's not that the rich are villains in this story, it's just that the financial sector channels their money into more fixed income debt-like products. I'm wondering what your take is not just on household debt, but debt taken on by companies and debt taken on by governments. Do they work the same way or do they, is there something fundamentally different about household debt compared to company debt and government debt?
当我们思考家庭 debt 与企业 debt 和政府 debt 时，我认为关键问题是这笔钱被用来做什么。我们在研究中做出的区分是，这笔钱是用于我们认为的生产性投资，还是仅仅用于产生消费。我们认为这两者之间应该有清晰的区分。因此，如果企业用这笔钱做有用的事情，建造工厂，建立新技术，那么当然，这是一件好事。我们绝不会说，哦，因为这个原因债务是不好的。
When we're thinking through household versus corporate versus government debt, I think the key question is what is the money being used for? And the distinction we make in our research is whether the money is being used for what we would think of as kind of productive investment, or if it's just being used to generate spending. And we think that there's a sharp distinction to be made between those two things. So, if corporations are doing useful things with the money, building a plant, building, you know, a new technology, then of course, that's a great thing. And we never would want to say, oh, debt is bad for that reason.
政府介于两者之间，因为政府可以利用债务融资来做一些富有成效的事情，比如修建桥梁、建造机场、改善拉瓜迪亚机场。但他们也可以利用债务来向人们转移资金，比如收入分配底层50%或90%的人，并促进他们的消费。所以在我们看来，真正的区别不在于销售政府或企业债务。而是生产性债务与我们所谓的非生产性债务。非生产性债务再次强调，是仅仅助长消费的债务。它没有被用于投资任何类型的生产性活动。
Governments kind of lie somewhere in between because governments can use debt financing to do productive things like building a bridge, building an airport, improving the LaGuardia airport. But they can also use debt to just transfer money to people and let's say the lower 50% or 90% of the income distribution and to facilitate their spending. So the real difference in our mind is not how sold government are corporate debt. It's productive debt versus what we call unproductive debt. An unproductive debt again is debt that's just fueling spending. It's not being used to invest in any kind of productive
政府其实介于两者之间，因为政府可以通过债务融资来做一些有建设性的事情，比如修建桥梁、机场、改善拉瓜迪亚机场。但他们也可以利用债务单纯地向民众转移资金，比如收入分配中底部的50%或90%的人群，来促进他们的消费。所以在我们看来，真正的区别不在于政府债务还是企业债务。而是生产性债务与我们所称的非生产性债务之分。非生产性债务同样是指纯粹刺激消费的债务。它并没有被用于投资任何有生产力的项目
activity. But I want to follow in any kind of productive activity. But I want to follow up on that for a second. I mean, aren't the two things related? So let's say I'm a company and I've invested in a new plant and let's say the new plant is making, I don't know, let's say it makes sweatshirts or water bottles. Now, for that to be a good investment, somebody has to buy those sweatshirts and those water bottles, which means somebody has to spend money. So I'm not seeing the neat distinction you're making between borrowing money to produce and borrowing money to buy, because presumably without the people who are buying, the people who are investing the money to produce will be making bad investments. Yeah, for sure. So let's zero in on household debt a little bit closer. When households borrow, the traditional good type of borrowing that we talk about in economic models is closely linked to the idea of spreading your income over time.
And so usually the idea is, right now, I'm not making as much money as I will in say 15, 20 years. Think about a 30-year-old just graduating from graduate school and needing to buy a house. And the idea is that it would be a good thing if that person can borrow today to say by a car, by house, knowing that their income's gonna get better over time, and then they will be able to pay back the debt when they get older. The problem with that story is that it's increasingly looking untrue and that is most of the people who borrow a lot, they never end up subsequently seeing very high income and so they often get into these debt traps where they just continue to owe and continue to owe and
continue to owe. There's a lot of research coming out, for example, that people are retiring now with just way more depth than they used to. This is closely linked to a lot of the stress, the elderly in this country are feeling, you know, about people having to work longer than they had planned. And so you're exactly right. There's a model of household debt that's quite good and can be productive, but that's just not the model that seems to be followed today in America. These are models in which, you know, our future selves are unhappy with the decisions we make today. You know, in five years, the Amar Sufi, five years from now, will be like, why did you borrow so much to buy that car? You didn't need that car. And I at least are kind of
pretty convinced that this way of thinking is the accurate way of thinking for most people. That most people make decisions today that five or ten years from now they may not be so happy with. And if that's the way people behave, then of course borrowing can be quite problematic because I'm being encouraged to do something that my future self will be unhappy that I did. So Amir, you grew up in Kansas and when you were growing up you had to do drills in school to prepare for tornadoes and it's an obvious idea. You want to prepare for bad times when times are good. It's a central idea behind insurance. You call debt the anti-insurance.
What do you mean by this? So debt works the exact opposite of insurance, in the following sense. If, for example, you have homeowners insurance and God forbid there's a fire, then the insurance company is gonna come to you and give you a payment to try to make you whole. Debt in fact works the exact opposite way,
which is house prices falling by 20% 40%, that can be as devastating to your wealth as a fire, but instead of the financial market coming to you and paying you if house prices fall, if anything, you bear the entire loss. And it gets back right to that example that I gave before, that if the economy collapses, if house prices in your neighborhood collapse, if you lose your job, debt doesn't really care. You know, debt still demands that you pay them. And so in that sense, it's the anti-insurance. There's no sympathy, you know, you wish debt had sympathy like a loved one would have sympathy, but it doesn't.
If you've lost your job, suppose you have a lot of student debt, you've got a new job, but then you lose it. You still got to make that student debt payment. They don't care that you lost that job. And that's the sense in which debt is just a really terrible financial product for the sake of in sharing risk across people. So policy makers often think of solutions when the economy is spottering and and their solutions often involve you know getting people buying and spending again
invariably what that means is getting people to borrow again uh... talk a moment about this i sense that you think this argument is like saying the best way to prevent a hangover is to stay permanently drunk exactly i think that i understand the appeal of this solution because it's a kind of band-aid solution. You know, it will even work in the short run. If you just get people to start barring again, then probably you're going to be able to boost the economy.
And maybe you should even do that at the depths of a crisis. The problem is, it's not a sustainable solution. Ultimately, it has to be that we tackle the more fundamental issue, which is why is there so much debt, why are people borrowing well beyond their means? And in my view, that's very closely connected to the idea of stagnating middle-class incomes, extreme income and wealth inequality. So even though there's an appeal to do these kind of short run, sugar rush solutions, let's just get people to borrow a little bit more to get past this, ultimately it's not going
to be sustainable. I'd point out even furthermore that we're starting to see that effect, that we're just not seeing very sustainable, high growth anywhere in the advanced economy world. And I think it's because we keep papering over the fundamental issues with debt. Amir Sufi and Artif Miyai argue that a financial system that thrives on the massive use of debt does exactly what we don't want it to do, it concentrates risk squarely on the debtor. When we come back, what this means for the recession caused by the COVID-19 pandemic and how we can keep the most vulnerable among us from suffering the worst consequences.
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Economist Amir Sufi and Atif Mian believe that household debt is one of the big drivers of recessions. The bigger the build-up of debt, the more households that owe a lot cut back on their spending. The more spending gets cut, the less demand there is for goods and services, which translates to layoffs and unemployment. Even more people now find themselves behind on their debt obligations, and even more people cut back on spending. It's a vicious cycle. One way to intervene is for the government to step in during a crisis and forgive people's debts.
But this isn't just difficult to do from a financial perspective, it's difficult to do psychologically. On May of 2009, as the Obama administration was trying to come up with ways to soften the blow of the Great Recession and to keep ordinary people from falling through the cracks, CNBC reporter Rick Santelli delivered an impromptu speech on the floor of the New York Stock Exchange. How about this President and New Administration? Aren't you put up a website to have people hold you? What did he say? He basically said, how dare we forgive debt for all of these people
who were so irresponsible and borrowed so much. And, you know, I always say tribalism is a very powerful force in human interaction. And so I think there's this effort to make the debtors and the creditors feel like different people and it's those debtors that have caused all this problem, how dare we help them in any way. This is America. How many human people want to pay for your neighbor's mortgage? It has an extra bathroom and can't pay their bills. Raise their hand. How about we
offer? It has a very powerful ring. I think when things go badly, oftentimes people are looking for someone to blame. And that complicates the policy efforts that maybe needed in order to help us experience a faster recovery. So you would argue that there is not just psychological reasons or moral reasons to try and potentially address the questions of debt, but there're also good economic reasons to do so. Someone can say, look, if someone else decides to borrow money, it's up to them to figure out how to pay it back. On the face of it, that's not an
unreasonable position, but you argue that the people who demand that borrowers always face up to their debt applications are sometimes cutting off their noses to spite their faces. How so? Yeah, exactly. And I think there's two, you know, before getting into the economics of it, I think there is an important point that needs to be made, which is it's surprising to me that more people don't also play some blame on the lenders. People made some really bad loans, they made some really silly loans. In fact, there's substantial evidence that lenders purposefully mistated information to get people to borrow more. So I'm all for having people who made bad decisions bear
the consequences of those decisions, but it seems like an unfair situation in which we only blame one side of the contract. That point is related to the economic point, which is our basic idea is that both the lender and the borrower should more equally share the losses that are associated with the crisis. It's not a radical proposal. We're not saying that of course borrowers should be forgiven everything and they shouldn't have to bear the consequences of borrowing too much. We're just saying that in the broad scheme of things, for fairness purposes, it seems
better to have a situation in which both the lender and the borrower bear some of the losses. It's not only more fair, but it's also better economics, because as we pointed out before, the borrowers are the ones that are going to massively cut back spending if you force all of the losses on the borrower. So by basically spreading the losses more equally, you actually not only do something that, in my opinion, is more fair, but only do something that in my opinion is more fair, but you do something that's actually better for the overall economy, because it's the collapse and spending that's really starting to affect everyone involved.
Is there an irony here that we don't like writing off the debt of the people in Detroit who took out say, our second mortgages on their homes, but we seem to have a more lenient approach to debt taken out by big corporations. You know, recent presidents like George W. Bush and Barack Obama have talked about the importance of saving big companies, and I've often heard the phrase, you know, some of these companies are too big to fail. Exactly. In fact, funny enough, I actually do teach corporate restructuring as my main
course I teach at the University of Chicago, a boot school of business. And it's kind of amazing how efficient. And to be honest, I think it's quite good the way the system works on the corporate side. You wipe out the equity holders, you wipe out some debt, you give the company over to people who run it, and it just goes forward. And there's so much less baggage in terms of moral arguments and whatnot, it just kind of moves forward. In fact, if you wrote down debt the same way for households as we often do for corporations, I think things would look quite naturally good and the economy would be a lot more resilient than it is.
So I completely agree with the premise of your question, which is I'm not sure why this is developed, where the people who are in some sense the ones that are most vulnerable are the people we decide that, you know, for sure they should bear the losses because they were irresponsible and they borrowed too much. So let's look at how we might think about debt differently in a couple of different settings. Let's start by looking, for example, at student loans taken out by the college class of 2020. Many of these students are graduating with large amounts of student debt
at a time when it's very hard to find a job. The repayments are going to begin soon. How could we balance the legitimate interests of lenders, borrowers, the students, and the economy as a whole when it comes to this problem. The answer to that question is closely connected to the example I gave before, which is the way in which the debt is born right now is squarely on the student. So let's take your example. Let's suppose the student has interest payments of say say, and debt payments of, let's say,
again, $2,000 a month that they have to pay, and they were expecting a job that would pay them $5,000 a month if there had not been this COVID crisis. Well now they're in a situation where they can't find a job, but they still owe that $2,000. The solution that we propose in our book is to make the debt instrument more equity-like. That is, if there is a massive crisis and unemployment goes up, the debt payment owed to the creditor would automatically go down. And you could do this in a number of ways. There's a number of implementations that you could do this.
Some countries already do this. For example, Australia does that. They have what's called income-based repayment. That if you earn less, you therefore are going to owe less on your debt. But the general idea is to try to make debt more flexible. It's the inflexibility of debt that leads to the problem. And you want to make it more flexible so it reacts to conditions that are going on in the economy. So if the lender says, you know, you're asking me to share in the risk if things go badly, do I share in the benefits if things go well?
Of course, that's how equity works and that's our proposal is to make the product more equity-like. That if you end up becoming the next Jeff Bezos, well, maybe I should get a higher payment if I helped finance your education. And again, this idea of making the debt contracts more equity-like is ultimately about bringing back who should bear the risk. And that is the richer people in the economy. And so we're not, you know, we're not people
Of course, that's how equity works and that's our proposal is to make the product more equity-like. That if you end up becoming the next Jeff Bezos, well, maybe I should get a higher payment if I helped finance your education. And again, this idea of making the debt contracts more equity-like is ultimately about bringing back who should bear the risk. And that is the richer people in the economy. And so we're not, you're not, we're not
who think risk is bad and should always be avoided. You know, finance is all built around risk, right? And taking risks should earn you a good return. It's just about the way that debt is making the wrong people bear the risk. And so these kinds of financial products that we're proposing, more equity-like products would help the rich benefit when times are good and they would pay the cost when times are bad and therefore the the
non-rich would have a more stable income stream, a stable payment that they're making, which would be better off for everyone. The same thing works with borrowing to buy a home. If mortgages were an equity instrument, rather than pure debt, what you owe each month would fluctuate. If home prices fall, your payments would fall, and fewer people would be at risk for foreclosure. But if you sell your home at a big profit,
the lender gets a cut of the upside. So if things go well, the lender makes out better. If things go badly, the lender loses. And that's exactly what we want. We want the lenders to have some skin in the game, some risk that they're taking. So a central argument that you're making is that most recessions often do not have an obvious cause like a war or a natural disaster. They sneak up on us and you suggest the build-up of debt is a big part of the story. The recession that we find ourselves currently in, however, is clearly the result of the COVID-19 pandemic. How is the story of debt relevant to what is happening right now in the present crisis. Your observation is 100% correct that this crisis, unlike the one in 2007 and 2008, did not originate with issues of debt. So that's
for sure. The broader issue I think we have now is that any shock like this shock is going to become worse if there's too much debt outstanding. We were pretty lucky in that debt levels were not at completely unsustainable levels when this crisis hit, but this crisis is really bad and it's going to lead to serious problems with people making mortgage payments, rent payments, credit card payments, especially if it continues on in the economy remains weak. And so, even though this crisis didn't originate with issues related to debt, debt will certainly amplify it unless we have a pretty strong policy reaction. Amir Sufi is a professor of economics and public policy at the University of Chicago Boots School of Business.
Along with Atif Mian, he is co-author of the book, House of Death, How They and You Caused the Great Recession, and How We Can Prevent It From Happening Again. Amir Sufi, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It was a real pleasure thank you for joining me today on Hidden Breath. It was a real pleasure, thanks for having me. This week's show was produced by Jenny Schmidt and Thomas Liu. It was edited by Tara Boyle and Raina Cohen.
Our team includes Paath Shah, Kat Chuknecht, and Laura Quarell. We had engineering help from Gili Moon. Our unsung hero this week is Armer's teenage son, Yasin. To record this interview, we needed Armer to have two smartphones. Yasin made one of the biggest sacrifices you can ask a teenager these days. He surrendered his phone for a couple of hours. The sound quality of this episode is much better thanks to your scenes generosity. Thank you, you're seen. For more hidden
brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If you learned something new from this episode, please be sure to share it with a friend. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.